him we've seen an incredibly high level
from the two quarterbacks in the afc
championship
josh allen and patrick holmes peter one
of the things that sims and i have been
talking about this week there are people
around the league who are starting to
think that maybe allen is every bit as
good as mahomes that there's no gap
there and that when you see him live
there is an element to josh allen that
doesn't come across on film doesn't come
across on tv it's the size it's the
speed it's the suddenness it's the
ability to go to the right and throw the
ball to the left
accurately and the accuracy has just
gone through the roof this year um when
you when you consider this one
you know you've got a chiefs defense
you've got a bill's defense maybe the
chiefs are a little bit better but let's
focus on the chief's offense assuming
patrick mahomes is going to play
do they do they rack up their 30 i mean
that's you know
with the chiefs you just kind of shrug
yeah they're going to get their 30 are
they going to get their 30 against this
bill's defense
well
here's an interesting point when you
think about josh allen and comparing him
to patrick mahomes
what we have seen is josh allen
be really great
over
a regular season
okay
i'm not minimizing
uh
how great a quarterback can be should be
whatever in a regular season but one of
the reasons why we look at patrick
mahomes right now among all the young
quarterbacks to be the king of the hill
is that he was behind by 10 points with
eight minutes left in a super bowl
having not played very well for the
first 52 minutes of this game
and he's down by 10 points
and he brings his team back with three
touchdowns in the last eight minutes
and my feeling about this is that
part of being a great player is being a
great player at the most important
moments
and that's why to me
josh allen is going on the road to play
the king of the hill on sunday
and i'm not saying you know show us what
you got buddy and you you're gonna be a
bum if you don't win i don't mean that
what i mean is that greatness is
determined by more than just how you've
played against miami in december
yeah you're absolutely right and this is
the moment where you step up or you
don't and we've seen patrick mahomes do
it now
we've got the concussion that he's
dealing with the toe injury that i think
may be worse than their advertising
we'll see he was clearly bothered by it
now he was running through it but when
he wasn't running he was hobbling and uh
you just wonder what kind of damage was
done over the course of that game
um on on sunday against the cleveland
browns but um you know peter we've seen
it that's the thing mahomes has shown it
josh allen hasn't and what a challenge
it is to prove yourself against a guy
who became the king of the comebacks
last year and even if you're up 24 it's
not safe so uh that's really what i'm
looking for and the other the other
thing
the bills were so dominant coming out of
their bye week down the stretch their
final
regular season games they were blowing
people off the field they haven't really
been that way you know it was a great
dominant defensive performance against
the ravens but they weren't you know
they haven't been that that pinball
machine offense that we saw in the
latter weeks of the regular season and
they're gonna need to be that if you're
gonna beat the chiefs you're going to
need to score more than 17 or whatever
it was 24 28 whatever it was against the
the the colts you're going to need to
get into the 30s and we've yet to see
that same spark from the buffalo offense
that we were seeing consistently late in
the regular season and when you look at
the chiefs defense i mean hey you know
we we don't focus on them because it's
all mahomes and the offense but
it's not going to be easy for the bills
to go out and bring up the kind of
points they need to overcome the kansas
city chiefs
absolutely right and and you know
playoff football should be harder you're
playing better teams you're you're
you're going to be in tougher games and
yeah they they beat the ravens the other
day uh you know 17-3
and it was i thought it was a great
performance obviously by that defense an
opportunistic defense in buffalo
but again this is when an offense that
is a high-powered offense with i think
three huge weapons in the receiving core
um and a very very good quarterback this
is when you have to respond mike and and
and like i said like i said no one on
sunday night
if the bills lose this game 31 to 14 is
gonna say ah you know josh allen see he
wasn't that good i'm not gonna think
that i don't care how he plays
um i still think he's a top five nfl
quarterback without any question
but
you
and and i think everybody who watches
this game
is going to know
if josh allen can get to that next level
because it is the perfect stage to get
to the next level
playing the big bad chiefs on their turf
and no matter what condition he's in
assuming he plays against
you know the reigning clutch great
quarterback in the game patrick mahomes
and it's it's
listen he will prove an awful lot by
winning this game
think about where josh allen was last
year and how much he's improved in one
year and i think the fact that that it
took him a while to kind of have that
spike
is what has some people saying yeah but
yeah but you know the texans playoff
game though in the aftermath of that
it's like man this guy's got a lot of
work to do to get
to the elite level and he did it he's
done it he's gotten there
and you know it's not going to be 51-3
like when the bills punched their ticket
against the raiders back in the 90s is
going to be a fight this is going to be
a huge battle whoever wins this game
i was about to say you know is really
going to be
well equipped to win the next game but
then i realize they're going to be
playing the packers of the buccaneers so
who the hell knows but
but still this is josh allen's moment
this is his opportunity and uh let's
hear a little bit from josh allen
regarding the offensive philosophy
heading into the afc championship
challenge at kansas city
we're not going to change who we are
like i said it's
it's obviously the biggest game like i
said because it's the next one but we
understand that we don't have to be
anyone different than who we are and
if we can go out there and execute and
play the game the right way and trust
each other and play complimentary
football
um you know all the results are going to
be pretty good
they have they lean so heavily though on
the pass
god they're going to need a running game
they're going to you know sims and i
were talking yesterday peter about which
team may be better off trying to slow
the game down and not get into a
shootout and there's an argument to be
made that the chiefs maybe are the team
that's better off doing that because the
bill's offense would be more likely to
have that frustration that angst that
they're not getting on the field they're
not able to do what they can do but i i
think they're i think this is one of
those games where they're just both
sides are going to go all out and try to
score as many points as they can
but at some point you're going to need
that running game and that's the big
question
for
for me as it relates to the buffalo
bills with zach moss out and devin
singletary kind of uh
and and they haven't been running josh
allen as much maybe this is the week
they finally unleash him as a runner to
keep the chiefs defense off balance but
they're going to need to find something
in the running game it can't be all pass
if they hope to to outscore the chiefs
you know what's so interesting also
about the chiefs team is you know we
gave uh jason light a nod you know early
but
you know
as well as convincing tyron matthew when
andy reid convinced him to to come to
the chiefs and and tyron matthew
basically in a lot of ways it's it's so
weird how a couple times in his career
and i know money plays a part but how
weird is it to watch tyron matthew and
how crucial he is to every defense he
plays on and twice he's been a man
without a country it's just it's just
very very odd
that a great player like him
important player on a defense for so
many reasons he's one of the top five
leaders in football right now
and that includes every position you
know and but but also
you look at what brett veach has done in
the draft in recent years and i bring
you exhibit a this year legerius snead
now look
uh i'm sure a lot of people who don't
really follow football have never heard
of legeria snead but last week in my
opinion when i watched that game i
thought he was the most important player
on a playoff defense and he's doing that
as a rookie
you know out of out of
you know out of all of the players
picked in this draft i don't he was a
middle round pick like fourth round pick
and he has come in
and been a precocious
brave
uh
incredibly
adept day one year one player for this
team and you just watched him against
cleveland play so well so smart in all
all facets of the game blitzing covering
and i just think a guy like him in in
this game
is gonna have a couple of things up his
sleeve
for a great receiving core in buffalo
well it will be his opportunity for
anyone out there who isn't aware of
luxurious sneed this is his chance to
get millions acquainted with him because
millions will be watching
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports